okay
you made it there you made it
dude I was like what the [__] is going
on
[Laughter]
come on hey
I go too far
dude that is bad
I sleep on that you making my stuff
dirty man I got that at Ross
[Music]
oh my God
a UK Medical Practice
a little oofy doofy for Christmas so
they mistakenly texted patients that
they have aggressive lung cancer instead
oh my God Merry Christmas
oh my god dude I could see how the
misspelling is very easy on those two
yeah
Merry Christmas aggressive lung cancer
hey mayor it's an aggressive lung cancer
but hey Merry Christmas that's true I'm
in cancer and Christmas pretty close
aggressive hey Mary yeah or he just
accidentally whoever was writing the
text message accidentally copy and
pasted the wrong thing and just sent it
right away when you get too cocky press
pace and then not too real I think it
makes more sense for somebody to be like
hey you have aggressive lung cancer and
happy New Year yeah oh that's nice
at least it's a good ending Progressive
lung kind sort of Happy New Year
that's really good how solid
[Laughter]
right that's bad news you've got cancer
but it's a lung cancer a little
aggressive Australian no no South
African might not make it what are you
talking about Australian New Zealand New
Zealand no what are you guys talking
about dude yeah that's not you that's
English that's Austria that's England
it's Brooklyn
baby so the mass tax from from askern
Medical Practice in Doncaster was on
December 23rd this is like uh the day
before Christmas Eve in it the practice
says the doctor asked the recipient to
fill out a form
ds-1500 which according to another UK
hospital system is meant for people who
have terminal illness to apply for
benefits the text also tells recipients
they have been diagnosed with aggressive
lung cancer with metastasis I wonder I
wonder if like if that went to the right
scam-oriented person they would
capitalize on that before the correction
was made somehow oh yes there's my Sue
opportunity me yeah right or like get
benefits from being you know when you're
terminally ill and you have a life
insurance plan you can claim it
two words for you one of them includes
an apostrophe s Ryan's wife oh I've
heard I've heard that Ryan is wild so
life life insurance is policies hey Ryan
if you did have a conscious I think
you'll be a pretty good criminal that's
what I was saying dude yeah really good
you got the knowledge he's got the
connections he's got the know-how and
the execution he's got the look he's
cool Under Pressure I'm just too
flawlessly heterosexual
flawlessly but he has morality a lot of
gay criminals today we've been talking
about by the way Morales you have
morality that's the disease you have
Morales yeah oh it makes you be a
stand-up human being you have Morales it
makes you cut up reals instead you don't
know what a Morales is
use my bathroom
but yeah you can't do that if you have
if you have life insurance plan uh
terminal illness is considered dying so
you can you can cash it in before you
die what I didn't know that how do you
know this because I got life insurance
hey but like if you but if you survived
you have to give it back because you're
like actually second life we're like
Ryan how do you know this he's like
because I read my policy plan because I
have like I don't think I read it
yo I got health insurance I never read
it once do you think that Ryan's deep
morality is what made him burn through
[__] red lights yesterday was trying
to come here because he's late
five minutes risking the lives of
thousands of motorized vehicle owners
I turned Google Maps into a family liar
is that five minutes you're like okay
check this out it's so tired too so
later on in the day a second text was
received by patients asking to accept
the the centers sincere apologies
because this has been sent in error our
message to you should have read we wish
you a very merry Christmas and a happy
New Year except for you Todd you
actually do have you I haven't
metastasized [__] it's all metastasized
all over Twitter do you guys send
Christmas cards like we got from one
family it's a cute little couple they
just had a little baby and then they're
like hey can I get your address Joe and
I was like why no one's asking me for my
address I'm like all right [__] it oh I
know who asked yeah yeah you're the
nicest couple in the world yeah it's one
of our lovely friends that lives in San
Francisco Sacramento and then um yeah I
got a Christmas card does them is the
cutest [__] with the baby and all that
and I was like yo do people still do
that [__] you put it on the fridge yeah
I still got a couple my brother did it I
got a buddy my fantasy football league
he did it I get that from my high school
friends there you go yeah I get that
from people and stuff like that usually
with people with family usually people
who did it the right way yeah but also
every year they'd look a little sadder
interesting
like in the
end of the fresh new family with a baby
what's this gonna be like and then like
oh I know what this is like oh this is
[__] intense yeah yeah I like to feel
it and then stand in front of like a
Christmas tree yard with an inflatable
[__] Santa and like there's like
something behind the eyes like I
honestly think that's Chico I think that
when you build a snowman and you put two
stones in the eyes
those eyes are more Earnest
ah as I see in these photos those ones
but these fathers who don't know what
the [__] they got themselves yeah yeah
Three Little Tikes now right it's always
the dudes it's the father in the phone
and it's like he's on this kid one is on
his lap one's on his shoulders like that
and he's like and it's on account that I
knew him before I'm like oh buddy I'm
staring into the abyss that's why like
as a photographer you really have to
look out for that yes like if you're
doing a family photo as a photographer
you're like hey hey hey
pretend like you like your life come on
dad you gotta pull them aside and be
like hey Richie pull it together for
this one hey just one shot I don't know
if I got it in me or else your wife's
gonna email me
[Laughter]
I was in my Corvette I was 21 years old
I had a good
you got to believe me why did I do it I
didn't look like this we was gonna open
the club we're gonna have the life you
know you remember remember the life
we're talking about Jimmy
can you tell me it doesn't watch It's a
Wonderful Life in the last two weeks
it's Richie [__] four
yeah so um failed lives yeah they
apologized
um to the roughly 8 000 patients eight
thousand yeah and they recognized the
excellent feedback that they are
receiving from patients regarding
telephone consultations afterwards the
excellent you love how they [__] melt
it all like they they gotta pivot it all
because dude I'll say this maybe this is
just my ignorance but if you are a
hospital is that what is it or clinic do
you really need to send Merry Christmas
texts to your [__] yeah
about and say happy holidays yeah yeah
yeah yeah they double down but maybe
when they do do that you feel like oh
they like me they care about me no for
sure and I understand that's why they do
it but then it's like but then you say
you guys all have lung cancer like
that's rough someone typed the wrong
[__] someone typed the wrong [__] I will
say though on a very very large and
unfortunate [__] up on something like
that if all 8 000 patients like were
able to kind of like forgive and like
laugh it off that must be a really cool
Community yeah that's a good point and
then there's that one [__] that's yeah
well one guy was like At first I thought
is this some kind of sick joke because I
only went in there for leg X-rays and
I'm like I got lung cancer
how do they see that that's [__]
Bonker balls somebody's like man I
thought I just had an STD like what the
[__] is going on so I was like man I
knew I should have moved out of La
another woman said who asked not to be
named she's like yeah that was pretty
[__] worried after this [__]
um because because her and some of her
family members went in for chest issues
oh [__] so then they got that so yeah
what is close to home versus confusing
lung cancer but then this chicken's like
oh I had chest issues so then she's like
oh [__] I might be [__] but then they
rang the doctors were put on hold as
usual and then she's like I walked
around I live around the corner and
there were like a bunch of other people
who were already there who got the same
test result she's like everyone got
[__] lung cancer results showing up
with the same outfit yeah mad exactly or
it's like Aaron Brockovich where it's
like something was in the water oh yeah
yeah hey what's the what's something
that you could have had that receiving a
lung cancer aggressivo text would be a
relief
eight okay straight to AIDS so what else
is on there they both seem like there's
only one one road to go yeah dude
Cancer's pretty fun thanks Joe for doing
the tier three of The Herald before we
finished I know but how you gonna hide
it from that baby if it was terminal
regardless I'd probably rather die of
lung cancer than like testicular cancer
really if it was terminal regardless oh
but when testicular cancer is terminal
is it this you just remove it yeah all
marrow cancers oh that's a sad that's
okay then that something like that you
know some terms are confusing because
we're like trying to get health
insurance for Tiger seizures and stuff
and I was talking to ladies like oh so
does your son have Ed and I was like
erectile dysfunction but it stood for
something else it's super something else
for kids tell me my four-year-old can't
get boner what the original dysfunction
and you got to do this I'd be worried
about what she said and I was like
you're like you better not be talking
about he is not a limp dick [__]
but he can get it up all right
have you ever had any doctors go hey
and he's Faking It
just take up making it you ever had a
doctor go he could be faking it that's
right jersey guy there's a context of
that bit that people don't know about
because tyke is a little bit of a faker
he's a [__] troll people
dude because you know doctors will say
they do that to women a lot like when
women come in with something like
they'll go ah it's fine hysteria I
diagnosed it you know what this
[__] so we're about to leave the
house at like around six we always bring
the medication because his medication's
at 6 45 7 right yeah we we have some
friends in town so we took him to go eat
closer to this trip and then it was like
5 30 and then we didn't realize it was
going to be like a long line and then
we're like me and you look at each other
like holy [__] it's six
we haven't sat down yet he's gonna need
his medication so I'm like we have to go
back and get your medication so we drive
back as we're driving back I was like oh
[__] it's getting close taika's sitting
next to me he's like this he goes death
look
my hand it's going limp like a
Cinderella he said look oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh
but he's not but he's not he's just
pretending you know he's not really like
like about to go in the full on seizure
but the fact that he knows like what it
is and he's like I can't control it I
can't control it that's so funny dude
that's so funny for example it was like
Thanksgiving like 1996 or some [__] when
I was a kid and I was like God damn it I
[__] hate pumpkin pie and my mom's
like you have to eat it we've got the
pumpkin pie you gotta eat it and then I
was like I'm not eating [__] [__]
around [__] pumpkin pie so I go into the
bathroom and then I'm like I'm like okay
I'm leaning over the toilet I'm like I'm
gonna think of [__] I'm gonna think of
poop I'm like
oh yeah I'm gonna keep thinking about
poop I'm trying to make sure I'm loud
enough right I turn off the fan right
because I was like oh that's too loud
because like the kitchen's like right
next to the bathroom
poop I'm like oh what if poop head
pumpkin pie
I actually made myself throw up after
eating the pumpkin pie no before so you
don't have to eat more and I was like
I'm not feeling gonna eat the pumpkin
pie and my mom's like fine that's how
much you hate pumpkin pie that's how
messy you ate it's fine now that's
[__] talented that you were just
thinking about you are at least
I'm telling you yeah
I was waiting I was waiting for Tyga to
be like oh no it's happening
I'm like taika you see your [__]
medication throwing it down the train
that's like that's the drawbacks of
having a kid so Elite in his sense of
humor yeah it's like ahead of its time
you shouldn't be doing knowing how to do
that yet no he's got the right Dad for
it you know somebody else who also has
the same level of intelligence you know
by the way his age will catch up to his
sense of humor and then it won't look
that impressive yeah
laugh it up while you can
[Music]